it really is it's it's a huge honor to
be here I love coming to this conference
I feel like I learned so much and you
know I'm probably the least capable our
programmer in this room I love coming
here and realizing everything I'm doing
wrong like I still set working directory
as even though Jared tells me every time
not to do that so so this is supposed to
be a stump speech about my research me
on the stuff I'm doing using satellite
imagery and machine vision computer
vision but I want to convey something
that I've learned about it through my
research that are relevant for for you
guys so I retitled this talk so it was
using satellite imagery and machine
learning to estimate conflict in Syria
and poverty in Mexico I'm gonna call
this wild speculation on the future of
data science when someone barely
qualified with two applications so and I
I think really the only the only thing
I'm Way I'm going to mollified I think
there's two qualifications that are
important here is that I'm tall and I'm
Jewish so so this is of course is of
course from Jared's wedding all right so
so I do I do have some qualifications I
was hired by Chapman University after I
finished off my degree where I teach are
a machine learning to MBAs and
undergraduates and in fact I have two
undergraduate students here whereas
Nancy and Andre Nance were they yeah
they're back there okay so 200 graduates
chaplain flew them all all the way out
from from California this is the first
time they've been in New York City Nancy
has a job but Andre you were still
looking for a job is that correct so if
somebody is hiring if somebody is hiring
an entry-level data scientist I give my
word that Andre knows what he's doing
so so I teach so I teach MBAs and
undergraduates but in my research I
mostly work in development economics so
I tried to solve problems in development
economics and one of the problems that I
focus on our data gaps data gaps are
problems where we just don't know a lot
about the developing world and one of
the startling statistics is that from
the period of 2002 to 2011 there are 57
countries that just had zero or one
poverty estimate and if you're somebody
like me who cares about poverty and
reducing poverty the fact that we're
just not measuring this at all should be
very startling and you'll see this
throughout the developing world we're
just not measuring things that are very
important and so the reason why we don't
do a good job of this is because it's
just it's really expensive like you have
to physically send somebody to your
summons household you have to interview
them for an hour - and you have to
figure out basically how much income
they have their areas can be located
very far apart and so visiting each
household is very expensive so even like
a very large country like Pakistan
you'll survey maybe maybe 20,000
households once every three or five
years and in fact in Pakistan there
there are places like Jammu and Kashmir
or the Northwest Frontier Province where
you just never you just never send
surveyors there and another another like
startling fact is in Nigeria we actually
have no idea how many people there are
like estimates vary between 200 million
and 140 million because every time they
try to run a census the government just
deletes a bunch of people because they
don't want certain places to have more
populations like it's just very
startling and so so my work is about a
lot of it is filling in these data gaps
you know one of the more popular data
gaps ways to fill this is you know look
at satellite imagery so maybe some of
you are familiar with this imagery this
is what you know if you look at a
satellite image mcnight you can kind of
tell well which one's North Korea and
which one's South Korea it's pretty
obvious
North Korea is the one without any
lights so in case you're wondering and
and that works really well for gross
just kind of grow statistics but we're
looking to do something a little bit
more with with with our numbers so so
and in particular I'm interested in
these like not just like these
old-fashioned satellites or what I'm
interesting is really like frontier
micro satellites so these are there's a
there's a start-up called plan
it that releases these like small
satellites that are size of shoe boxes
and they currently have 190 in orbit
they have more satellites in orbit than
any other country besides the United
States and China and so they have daily
revisit rate of all of the Earth's land
mass and they can start you can start
doing some really crazy things with this
data so yeah and we're just launching
like a crazy number of imagery
satellites so if any of you are
searching for a dissertation topic it's
just probably something that like what I
did I was just like I have no idea what
to work on so I'm gonna start messing
with satellites because there's probably
something here so previous work that
I've done as I've tried to you generate
intermediate features from satellite
imagery so I use computer vision to
extract out the number of cars under
number of buildings so this is a raw
satellite image of Sri Lanka Iran it's
kind of like an off-the-shelf computer
vision algorithm against there I could
figure out the number of buildings and I
can figure out the number of cars and I
threw that used R in order to just pump
that through and build a prediction
model of the amount of poverty in an
area so to push that a little further I
wanted to see like could I do this
directly from daytime satellite imagery
using the fancy new stuff the
convolutional neural networks directly
and you can kind of tell like like
there's a lot so if we look on the left
we see that this is a very well-off area
in Mexico City so this area has like
large streets it has a lot of green
areas on the right this is a poor area
buildings are more regular they're a
little more closer together the streets
are kind of crappier and then the
poverty rates are are accordingly so as
we in the previous work I tried to tell
the computer what are the poor areas
what are the rich areas so now I'm just
asking the CNN to figure out what are
the visual features that are the poor
areas have and this is like a read this
is a really hard cast to do because
there's just not a lot of data so we're
trying to do this at the municipality
level in Mexico and there's 2,500
municipalities so this is this is this
is very hard and so a lot of people
would say this is impossible
so we're going to do transfer learning
against this so
we're gonna do is we're gonna take like
an off-the-shelf CNN model which
truthfully I don't even understand this
like I understand the end point we're
all this is pre trained using imagenet
so it's been seen like millions of
images it's learned like all the
intermediate like weights effect
effectively or excuse me
Jared those are coefficients right yeah
yes okay so we're gonna learn all these
intermediate weights and at the end
we're just gonna replace whereas this
whole network was trying to produce to
figure out what like if it was a car or
maybe a cat or a dog or hot dog we're
gonna replace that last layer and just
say try to predict poverty like if you
learned all these intermediate things
that are useful for figuring out a hot
dog or not and now you're gonna figure
out if it's a poor neighborhood in
Mexico or a rich neighborhood in Mexico
and so this part was not done and this
was done in in Python and Theano
and you had some details on on Mexico so
we're using two poverty levels kind of
severe and moderate poverty and then you
know we do some nice withholding a
temperature municipalities and but we're
training this off of 900 municipalities
these are the only municipalities that
are surveyed by Mexico it's suppose to
be representative but that's a separate
story and so we trained on 800 these and
then we're gonna see how performs of the
test samples so let's look how performs
okay so it's not not a perfect fit so we
get our squares between 0.4 and 0.5 but
still this is better like imagine in a
country where you have no data
whatsoever so this is and so see if
there's something else we can do so we
also can do land classification so we
could look at the we could ask ask the
to train a classifier and say okay what
type of area is this is this a road is
this a building and I think this is
super cool because we trained this
against the planet satellites so this
has daily revisit rate meaning that this
is every road in Mexico and if you
wanted to you want to throw this
algorithm against new plant images you
calculate the changes and roads for
Mexico and you can do this anywhere in
the world
so I just think this is like like likes
loads better than trying to do surveys
and then if we include this land clapper
classification our model it improves it
a little bit and we get these predicted
problems poverty for urban areas in
Mexico okay so what's a lessons we can
take away like I think I think a lesson
here is that like using off-the-shelf
data like if you were just sitting in
your art console trying to trying to
estimate something there's this concept
in economics like the efficient market
hypothesis so like if a data set is out
there is it probably somebody who is
minded to write their dissertation or to
do some analysis so I I think like if
you're in a field where prediction
you're trying to predict something in
the real world and you're using the same
data that everyone else has like you're
probably not gonna do better than them
or better and the way you would really
get an edge is by just generating some
data that somebody else doesn't have so
you probably don't have to go to the
lengths that I'm going to but like just
try to get some new data and in many
cases generating new data or getting
some new data is going to be better than
using a better algorithm okay so the
second project I'm going to talk about
is really really recent stuff the
motivation here is we have a lot of
information on where violence is
occurring in the world but that
information is biased it's outdated and
its imprecise so it's a lot of the
information on violence it's recorded
either by hand so that there's some
eyewitness who says like there was a
violent event here in Syria in this
location or it's actually recorded from
YouTube videos because every like every
Syrian army like has like a YouTube
video where they post and say we bombed
this building and so we actually don't
know the full extent of damage or
violence because maybe there could be
delay where when the videos were posted
or maybe there is some bias and just
what was reported if somebody was there
and if you think about this you know
like the point of bombs is that they're
supposed to
to do some type of damage that should be
visible some space this is an area in
Homs Syria and you can see that there
are some there's some detectable damage
from these bombs and so we can utilize
some some of the same computer vision
technologies and we're gonna so we can
utilize that same technology in order to
tell whether an area as a destroyed
building or not and this is the dream is
that you're running this in real time so
this is running on daily updated
satellite images and like we're like far
away from that but we're like inching
towards towards that goal so we located
380 training sites in Syria with visual
identified building damage and we
eventually want increase this to a
thousand but right now this just shows
through in 280 locations and then we do
this process of data augmentation which
is like cropping and stretching and
skewing the the images that increases
this to 5,000 so we have about 5,000
images to Train off of and we're gonna
train two classifiers one for this
planet like fastly updated imagery and
the other one for the Google Maps API
okay the labeling process is pretty
straightforward we just pull up some
some image in Google Maps we're taking
1250 by 1250 images and then the label
we just try to figure out what do we
think is a is a destroyed area and so
anything that's a story area gets a 1
and everything else gets a 0 and the
we're gonna ask the CNN to try to figure
out some type of mapping between those
two some visual mapping the architecture
is gonna be we're kind of starting from
a place we're using like a building
architecture like this is this has been
used to detect buildings so it's you
know it's it's kind of its fancy
sandwich of things that are happening in
the CNN and if you do computer vision we
like there's there 7 cnn's there is that
are there stacked against each other and
then we take output for the first the
second in the seventh and use that and
create a stack feature map to do pixel
wise so the end result is we get a pixel
that says whether it's the destroyed
building or not we do some like advanced
stuff because that wasn't working out
too
well so I talked to my like people who
really do computer vision because I'm an
economist believe it or not and like
they say no you want to use this you net
architecture so we kind of like make it
a little more fancy all right
training notes all this is done in
theano it's run off Microsoft is your
server where where's mark
Heisman who's saying mark you were
saying like you're right like like
Microsoft Azure platform is really
fantastic yeah it's really fantastic
it's super expensive though so like so
I'm burning through money like I'm
spending like $1,000 a month so if you
have credits you can give me because aw
AWS is they offered me $30,000 and like
I really don't I really don't want to
take my research we'll talk okay
can we talk online no it but he's
absolutely I'm giving a hard time but
he's absolutely right it's a great
platform you can you can load up a
virtual server and so we have 2k 80 GPUs
and it takes about four days to run but
we're able to estimate the model in that
time and so all this is we're all
working off of a twenty thousand dollar
research grant from Lakeisha and it's
kind of you know we started this like
six months ago so and we can see the
preliminary learning anything that's
read as a building anything that's
that's not or is it anything that's read
a destroyed building and we see like
it's kind of learning that things
towards the top right are destroyed
buildings kind of starts out thinking
everything's destroyed building then it
stops and then the final after eight
hundred passes of the data we get
something that sort of closely
approximates the input and you could say
like every data scientist here is saying
that's super easy because that's an
in-sample so we can look at some of the
out-of-sample results and they look
pretty damn good so they're not perfect
we're still you know we're working
through the training data and the more
training day we throw into it the better
but they look pretty damn good if you
care about confusion matrices you can
roughly we're getting about 90
accuracy at the pixel level so next
steps we really want to use this to
predict refugee flows this is where
we're actually economists is we're gonna
look at this from like a micro economic
standpoint people are making decisions
about where to go on the basis of is
there you know is there safety in this
their narratives and so we're having
micro economic models that are going to
predict where somebody travels to we
want to also analyze reporting biases
for different type of conflict and yeah
so what's the lesson here
so this is actually backwards you know
the data we're building our models and
like a lot of our statistics ISM based
around static data data comes in you get
like you get a CD you get some thumb
drive it comes in and we're building our
data off of that we're building our
models off that data and this we our
whole project was on the idea of that
like data is going to be coming in real
time and we want to build our models
that are gonna incorporate that and so
so maybe maybe the goal here isn't
necessarily to build the best model to
build something that is useful for
people on the ground for humanitarian
workers and so this is I got this
completely wrong because it's a really
dynamic model is gonna be better than
static model so static model is going to
break if it sees stuff in in real time
and it's not it's not able to adjust so
completely opposite lesson here but okay
alright so that's everything I want to
present so any comments or suggestions
are appreciated if you want to give me
money research money that's great or if
you want to talk to me about group lasso
because I've got a project where I'm
where I'm doing some group lasso stuff
okay all right thanks so much
[Applause]
you